what's one thing that you advise like or
do for yourself in the morning
to go and be you that day okay well what
I do in the morning is I work out okay
every day every day oh pretty much no
Drew really you just it's like you just
need you've got to do hard cardio to get
that to get yourself I'm sorry you do
I'm just you do is we eat it in our
bodies we need it but we need it in our
brains your brain needs it how long
[Laughter]
[Music]
you find something that actually makes
you feel joyful while you're doing it or
it won't work because this is not going
to get her done
okay that's good that's okay all right
then I'm gonna do it in the morning in
honor of you I'm gonna start and I've
got to be
with it